well the great school supply drive is
back rocky theas is at smith's one of
the sponsors of the event to find out
how the community
is coming together to help students as
they head back to class
we are so excited to welcome back the
great school supply drive with channel 8
of course and smith you guys
have been coming in it started today
july 19th it goes through july 29th and
already
there are some really great donations
for our kids now deb you mentioned that
of course i'm gonna pay for this and
actually donate and i'm giving you a
twenty-nine
so out of your change you can donate
that and we'll be happy to buy the
supplies and fill the box too
that is awesome so definitely keep the
change dev so i'm going to throw this in
there
and we're going to take my basket to
the donation box and of course we're
going to talk to
bob day with smith who's going to tell
us more details about the drive hey
i got i love that stuff appreciate it
yeah and i totally keep the change
all right even better all right so let's
talk about what
we are donating to the community so we
um of course
we're donating back to school supplies
so we've been able to to partner with
channel 8 again
this year in order to get the supplies
needed for for the kids
and of course they're going to need
everything from paper to crayons to
pencils
and you know paper towels kleenex
surface wipes those are all the things
that are really going to be even more
important this year as everybody's going
back to
to school amid the whole covid thing of
course hannah sanitizer will be a new
new thing that is very on in demand i
mean how does it feel you know speaking
of covet to come back
with the with the great school supply
and partner with channel 8 now
you know we're really excited to be able
to do this because obviously last year
we weren't
it was very limited back to school
if there even was back to school at that
point in time so we're excited to be
able to get back out there to
really be able to help the the kids and
and the things that they need in order
to
to have a successful school year
absolutely so let's move over here now
to the
great drop box i should call i just
named it that is okay bob
i'm going to hand you the mic okay so
tell us tell us what we're doing
okay and so so what we're seeing so far
already is
a lot of backpacks that have been
donated you see the paper
and the pencils and everything like that
that's been donated and so a lot of just
basic supplies that the
students are going to need in addition
with with smith's we're also doing a
lunch drive
so you can pay a dollar fifty at a check
stand and pay for lunch for a student
that is incredible thank you guys so
much for what you're doing and of course
the channel eight thank you for being
involved with this
great opportunity um i really feel good
after putting my items in that box so
thank you for letting me
get back to the community too yeah and
the boxes are in the front of every
single store
so you purchase your items and drop them
on the box on the way out that's awesome
thank you so much bob
thanks all right everybody head to your
local smith and donate for our kids